Matt Lauer and Garrison Keillor both
fired for weird sex stuff Joe
Scarborough accused of murder
Muslim videos showdown at the CFPB there
is so much news to talk about but isn't
it strange that nobody is talking about
the tax reform bill passing the budget
committee yesterday I wonder why that is
we will analyze Donald Trump's slick
fingers then Philip Wedman of the
Washington Examiner and Paul Bois of The
Daily wire joined the panel of
deplorable z' to discuss how we're
finally winning the war on Christmas a
descendent of Pocahontas max Don
Elizabeth Warren and today's spate of
Democrat sex scandals just a reminder
every single day now there have been
entirely new Democrat sex scandals
I am Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show
there is so much to talk about we will
get to all of the weird sex stuff and
the schadenfreude I promise but I want
to talk a little bit first about Donald
Trump the prestidigitator the
prestidigitator he's got slick fingers
the actual story the one that matters
for Public Policy right now is tax
reform we have been hearing for months
by the way from never Trump Republicans
that tax reform is dead on arrival as
impossible we're not going to get it the
left predictably has been harping on how
awful the proposal is how it's gonna
it's only going to benefit rich people
it's only gonna cut their taxes because
obviously rich people are the only ones
who pay taxes but actually the bill is
quite different than all that Trump has
been relatively mum on tax reform he
talks about it here and there why is
that of the is 31 latest tweets three of
them mentioned tax cuts and by the way
only to acknowledge that it passed the
committee or to start tying the tax cuts
to the good economic news seven tweets
talked about how great the economy's
doing
once we mentioned the NFL 3 mentioned
Melania Christmas or Melania and
Christmas two of them mentioned Matt
Lauer almost as many tweets mentioned
Matt Lauer as his legislative agenda
three showed videos of Muslims doing
terrible things that's the same number
as talking about tax cuts 3 talked about
fake news one suggested that Joe
Scarborough murdered a staffer one of
them told his followers to look into NBC
chairman Andy Lacs past why is Trump
tweeting about these things it's because
he's a prestidigitator if you don't know
that word that's not like Amanda's name
Prestage jacquimo it's prestidigitator
it's a word for people of quick fingers
like a magician magic where it's a slate
of hand that is prestidigitation look
over here look a look over there what's
that and then when we're looking at that
thing something else is happening over
here so of all these tweets why is he
talking about each of these the economy
is obvious he's trying to try this try
the strong economy to his tax plan he
talks about how great the economy is
doing how great the economy is doing
he's building up his credibility on the
economy then he's saying we need this
new economic agenda this new economic
legislation why Matt Lauer Matt Lauer's
the biggest news of the day he has been
fired for apparent sexual assault in Rio
de Janeiro but apparent
rampant womanizing sexual harassment at
NBC but he doesn't just leave it in Matt
Lauer
he doesn't just look it would be great
to revel in Matt Lauer going down that
guy is a jerk he's a left-wing hack he
was a jerk to President Bush when he
would interview him but he's not doing
that Trump isn't just leaving it in
schadenfreude he's tying it to Joe
Scarborough why because he's trying to
discredit the left-wing attack dog
immediate he's trying to paint with a
much broader brush that's why he's going
after NBC Chairman Andy lack now why is
he tweeting about the NFL the NFL is a
culture culture point with that is
extremely popular for Donald Trump he
has broad agreement across the country
on this his approval rating is doing a
lot better than the NFL's approval
rating people are cutting cable because
of the shenanigans and left-wing
activism they see every night at the NFL
and why the Christmas tweets well they
they preview the war on Christmas theme
which we're already beginning to see but
I promise you were gonna see more of it
this month why the Muslim videos the
Muslim videos I think tell a lot of the
story he was retweeting videos of
Muslims doing awful things attacking
people and beheading a statue of the
Virgin Mary and they were all posted by
Jada France and she's the deputy leader
of Britain first which is a right-wing
group and this woman who is she he
doesn't follow her on Twitter right he
only follows 45 people on Twitter why
tweet her this is a woman who was found
guilty of a hate crime so the left is
freaking out about this they say he's
retweeting far-right criminals hate
criminals bigots whatever what was her
hate crime a simple Google search will
tell you her hate crime was saying that
Islam oppresses women that was the crime
because they don't have the First
Amendment over there and in the UK they
don't have freedom of speech you can be
convicted of a hate crime for just
saying something which is obviously true
obviously Sharia law isn't good for
women a rule that says that women need
to wear burlap sacks over them in Middle
Eastern heat that can't possibly be good
for women any concept we have on the
west of women's rights does not apply
now free speech though and PC these
aren't just random issues there's
central issues too Donald Trump's
popularity and and this is where the
claim breaks down why the
the nevertrump right and his opponents
on the left they say he's just crazy
he's just tweeting whatever there's no
rhyme or reason to it he's a madman with
his finger on the nuclear codes and the
other finger on Twitter there's no
evidence that Donald Trump hates Muslim
people there's no evidence in the four
decades that we've known about Donald
Trump we we've never seen these
allegations of bigotry before it clearly
it has to serve a strategic purpose or
we're suggesting that he just became a
bigot overnight that he just became in
his Lama folk overnight or something and
he just so happened to pick a woman that
ties in directly with his Auntie PC Pro
free speech agenda it doesn't work at a
certain point either the guy just gets
lucky and lucky and lucky and he's
absurdly lucky at multiple things at one
time for 40 years or he doesn't just
have air blowing between his ears he
doesn't just have nothing going on in
his head he has some strategic thought
and a good gut that tells him had a had
a enacted tactically so what is he not
tweeting about this is the actual story
I'm perfectly willing to talk about it
because it's a great wing for the
Republicans and for conservatives and
because the left-wing media doesn't
watch my show so I don't think I'm
telling any tales out of school or
pulling the veil up on this he isn't
talking about tax reform but what was he
doing yesterday Trump spent most of
yesterday on Capitol Hill bullying
Republican senators into voting for the
GOP tax reform in the Budget Committee
according to a Senate source for the
hill Trump went after Ron Johnson by
name quote this is in the hill he told
him to stop blocking it and to work out
his concerns with the rest of the
conference he told him he would have a
chance to offer amendments and he should
stop being an impediment a Trump also
leaned on bob corker and James Lankford
both of whom are Republicans that
threatened to vote against the bill in
committee Senate GOP Whip John Koren
said it was Trump strong-arming that
gave the bill quote a shot of adrenaline
it gave this bill that everyone has been
predicting on both sides of the aisle
it's going nowhere
it's gonna die in committee not so gave
it some momentum last month Trump also
met with the entire Senate GOP caucus to
get them on the same page on tax reform
now
to analyze all of this prestidigitation
and the tax reform bill and the
likelihood that it passes we bring on
our panel of deplorable x' we have Paul
Cardenal Bois from The Daily wire and
we're lucky to be joined by Philip
Wegman from the Washington Examiner look
how much realer by the way how much more
serious Philips background looks than
Paul's who appears is coming from st.
Peter's Basilica the Vatican
so gentlemen thank you for being here I
really appreciate it I want to get to
this tax reform Philip are we going to
get it you're you're a serious
journalist you have sources you're
paying attention to in DC or are we
going to get tax reform if so when
certainly the president hopes that it's
gonna happen ahead of Christmas I don't
know if that's actually going to get
done sometimes it sounds a little bit
like wishful thinking he had that
productive meeting with Republicans
earlier on but if you start taking a
look at some of this the objections I
mean the whip count is getting pretty
ugly
you've got Collins who objects to the
individual mandate you've got Ron
Johnson that you just mentioned and then
also Lankford and some others and then
you know I have no idea what John McCain
thinks about you know regular order he's
voted against tax cuts twice before and
Republicans just they can only lose two
votes so the whip count is really ugly
this one's gonna come down to the wire
it's certainly going to come down to the
wire I don't know what John McCain
thinks about regular order I don't quite
know what he thinks about these tax cuts
but I do know what he thinks about
Donald Trump and what he thinks about
his legacy and that does not look good
for us
mr. voix make me happy or lighten me up
are we gonna get tax cuts and then I
then I want to talk about the Trump enos
of it all but first do you think we're
gonna get it I mean it really is all up
in the air right now I mean the biggest
problem that we have going on right now
is mainly there's the GOP just getting
it all together I sincerely hope that we
were going to get health care reform and
the GOP didn't deliver that so it's
really just I mean can they all come
together right now and as right now I'm
not seeing that and this is that coming
together is is a question because the I
think the most cogent argument from
the nevertrump right the persistently
nevertrump right is well Donald Trump
engages in these crazy excesses you know
like accusing Joe Scarborough of murder
on Twitter or something or implying the
Joe Scarborough had some hand in this
staffers death and therefore if we
Republicans if we conservatives enjoy
the successes and there have been many
successes of this administration both
culturally and politically as real
matters of government if we enjoy those
or if we encourage those or if we vote
for him then we own Trump we own his
excesses we'll have to answer for them
and we'll look really bad or something
we won't be able to preen as much as we
would like to preen Philip do you think
that's true do you think that if we
encourage Trump to in his presidency
that we're going to have to face some
awful reckoning in the future I think
the reckoning already took place I mean
the president is the president because
he won the election but guys like
Lindsey Graham who were adamantly
opposed to the president earlier on
they're coming around I mean Lindsey
Graham's as establishment as you can get
but he's even willing to work with the
president because I think a lot of these
guys know in the White House isn't the
only thing up for grabs they're also
gonna lose their majorities if they
don't deliver something so yeah there's
that long game there's that that fear of
what are we going to do with Donald
Trump what's he gonna do to our party
and our identity but I think in the
moment at least on tax reform I think
these guys are willing to put away some
of that bickering and focus on the bill
itself and I do think there is an aspect
of Trump which is just that he is a
character he's a one of a kind he's an
American original we talked yesterday
about how there's no need to have the
Jersey Shore or a reality television
when Donald Trump the king of reality TV
has made reality into reality TV he's
the best show in town he is the best
show in town and I think Camille Paglia
Paglia said that she would vote for him
because he's a carnival barker and she
likes that and there is something it
seems to me that he isn't he doesn't
pretend to be a regular Republican he
doesn't even really pretend to represent
the mainstream of
Servat of movement or of the Republican
Party he's his own self
mr. Bois do you think that his
caricature and the caricature that he
plays up for the cameras and for Twitter
do you think that that will inoculate
conservatives or should we be terribly
worried about our own image and
constantly looking in the mirror and
saying well who cares if we get all
these great things accomplished for the
country how will I look when when it's
all over I think that kind of pearl
clutching regarding president from
really is going to do nobody any favors
and that was part of I think every
voters just worried throughout the
election and then the issue that they
had to struggle with internally was by
going in with President Truman am I
going to you know be destroying myself
in the future but I think we all got a
man up and just be like all right we're
in this I mean we are in an existential
threat you know culturally so I say you
know get rid of that fear of dive in and
you know on terms of like what Trump has
been successful at and and his excesses
and should we be more worried about his
excesses I think we got a really define
like what what we want Trump really to
be successful and I really do not
believe that we elected Trump for
anything legislatively I think we
strictly elected him so he can be the
guy when Colin Kaepernick is being a
complete jerk to all of us and spitting
on the flag he just says throw that you
know sob out and next thing you know
we're all cheering and we feel like we
got ourselves a culture of cheerleader
and then we know we're embolden and we
feel like we can go out there and we can
stick it to the people who are telling
us what to do and what to say and that's
why we elected him and that he has been
100% successful and we should not be
worried I have agree with you but I must
say I am compelled by Ann Coulter's
argument that we elected this guy for
issues he was talking about issues that
other people weren't talking about he
was talking to a group of voters that
both parties ignored and he sure I like
when he calls out Colin Kaepernick as
much as the next guy that's very
important politics follows culture the
culture is key here it's related cult is
related to culture it's related to what
we worship
and certainly that's the case everything
else is just accounting you might say
that said there have been great policy
victories we've seen them obviously on
the courts up to Neil Gorsuch we've seen
them in massive deregulation in trying
to rein in these awful godless headless
unaccountable executive agencies we've
seen it in foreign policy we've seen it
in social policy like the Mexico City
rule like abortion pro-life he's been
excellent on so yeah certainly the
culture is maybe the key aspect of Trump
but he's given us a lot of policy
victories and it just I really wouldn't
want to see all of that go away I
wouldn't want to turn my back on that
just because I'm uncomfortable with him
making hilarious and probably a little
excessive claims about Joe Scarborough
or whatever I love that show I love the
prestidigitation and we have much more
to talk about by the way speaking of the
culture we have much more to talk about
on the war on Christmas we have to talk
about all of the weird Democrat sex
stuff and we have to dance on Matt
Lauer's professional grave because what
would this show be without a little
schadenfreude ax it is fun we should do
it he's been a jerk to the right for a
long time but if you don't subscribe to
The Daily wire I'm sorry you can't see
it we appreciate all of our current
subscribers they help us keep the lights
on they help us keep coffey in my cup
they even helped us get serious
journalists like Philip this is like a
first over here we usually just have the
cafe panel but we've got serious
analysis going on but you can't see that
unless you go do daily wire.com right
now what do you get you get me at the
inter Clavin sure you get the Ben
Shapiro show no ads on the website blah
blah blah look all that's just
accounting folks isn't it because what
you could get is the cultural touchstone
here the leftist tears tumblr as I think
nobody will be left in Hollywood other
than Kevin Sorbo maybe and nobody will
be left in the media except probably Ben
Shapiro so when all of those leftist
tears start flowing and everyone is
drowning in them make sure that you have
a vessel so you don't drown you can keep
them hot or cold always salty and
delicious go to the Daily wire calm
right now we'll be right back
let's get to the war on Christmas I love
the war on Christmas almost as much as I
love Christmas I especially love winning
the war on Christmas President Trump
promised repeatedly throughout the
campaign that we would turn the Yuletide
in the war on Christmas see what I did
he's doing just that Melania has hung
mistletoe all around the White House
hubba-hubba
president Trump unlike his predecessor
has sent out a Christmas card things are
looking up
you know leftists mock the war on
Christmas they always they say it's
imaginary Barack Obama's 2016 White
House Christmas card did not mention the
word Christmas not once it says Happy
Holidays the White House social
secretary Desiree Rogers even says that
Obama wanted to ban the crash the
nativity scene from the East Room of the
White House although tradition
eventually won out because that would be
egregious president Trump's card says
Merry Christmas and Happy New Year which
makes sense because those are the only
two major holidays this season I say
major there is Chanukah of course which
is an ancient Jewish holiday but it has
always been relatively minor and remains
relatively minor outside of the United
States it's taken on greater currency in
the u.s. because to reform rabbis in
Cincinnati decided to reinvent the
festival of lights
as a Jewish answer to Christmas during
the late 19th century that's all nice
I'm from Westchester everybody
celebrates a basically a more Jewish
version of Christmas they're more power
to them there's also Kwanzaa a
completely contrived socialist pseudo
holiday invented in the late 1960s by a
criminal and LA city college professor
of Africana Studies named Maulana
Karenga who was convicted in 1971 of
imprisoning women while sexually
assaulting them while he whipped them
with electrical cords branded their
faces poured detergent down their
throats and hit them on the head with
toasters approximately 0.2% of the world
celebrated Kwanzaa as of 2012
now to top it all off here is a clip
from the last journalist in America
comedian Stephen Colbert as Stephen
Colbert steven crowder okay Alexa who is
the Lord Jesus Christ Jesus Christ is a
fictional character Alexa who is the
Prophet Mohammed
the Prophet Muhammed is very wise
prophet he taught me people how to live
he had a wife called aya he lived in
Saudi Arabia the message that he gave to
the people is prayed to Allah he is the
only God and he gave the holy corn I
think you know I think that clip got cut
off the first question was who is Jesus
Christ and Alexis says is a fictional
character he's a fictional character
created I don't know when I guess in the
first century
Paul Cardinal blah let's start this with
you is there a war on Christmas and
should we be fighting of course there's
a war on Christmas - yes yes there's
been a war on Christmas going on in this
country all the way going back to the
1960s believe it or not yeah I know we
all love the Charlie Brown Christmas
then that famous scene where Linus reads
from Luke's Gospel CVS and the producers
on that show did not want that in there
I mean they they fought tooth and nail
to try and get it out eventually of
course Charles Schultz being a religious
man he won out in the end and and then I
think for that you know you got to see
what Charlie Rose did to Lucy this is
people haven't been talking about this
investigated folks and in 1992 you know
frosty we all remember Frosty the
Snowman frosty returns completely and
totally eliminated all references to
Christmas it was basically just this
soviet comas are approved version of
Frosty the Snowman there was no
reference of Christmas no reference of
Santa it was all this environmentalist
message about the importance of snow it
was bizarre and that was in 1992 and
ever since then I mean we just had
storefronts saying happy holidays as
you've noted I mean throughout all eight
years of Barack Obama's presidency I
don't think his Christmas cards said
Merry Christmas they always said happy
holidays or season's greetings so you
know we're we're we're in it and the
president Trump is delivering on that
he's making Christmas great again and I
loved Melania I love
milania's designs for the Christmas
decorations in the White House this year
I know left us on Twitter or giving her
hell for it and they're just saying all
kinds of wicked things about it but I
think I think it's great I think we have
a lot to be celebrating about this year
you could just say that sentence . i
love Melania I love Melania that woman
is all Grace and class she has been
fabulous is she is a great first lady so
Phillip or the lefties being
disingenuous when they claim that there
is no war on Christmas or the war on
Christmas doesn't matter because the war
on Christmas sure seems to matter to
them there are the aggressors in this
they're the ones trying to change the
tradition is it is it disingenuous do
they really know the stakes what are the
stakes well I think conservatives
definitely fall for it when they go with
the war on Christmas narrative we've
seen all the ridiculous arguments over
Starbucks cups and you know some
teenager who's bagging our groceries
being told he has to say happy holidays
or Merry Christmas
like I think that the solution here is
that you know for for conservatives
freedom is the solution here if you want
to say Merry Christmas go ahead and do
that but don't throw a fit because you
know you have arista said happy holidays
instead I get that there are some people
who are trying to change the culture and
you know a race the you know the
nativity I don't think that works I
think they just look really silly and so
yeah absolutely the the White House
looks beautiful I'm glad there's a
nativity scene back in there but the
only present that's really going to
matter when Trump moves out of the White
House you know either in three years or
seven years when he moves out the only
thing that's gonna matter is whether or
not he got tax reform done whether or
not he got health care through so yeah I
mean I never stopped saying Merry
Christmas
neither did my family and back home in
Indiana I mean everybody
at basically every store so I think it's
it's overblown and we all do ourselves a
disservice when we when we get into it I
think what is kind of a petty fight but
Indiana is a great state it's one of the
finest states in this union they elected
mitch daniels for goodness sakes the
indiana might not be representative of
the whole country and I will say it
isn't just baristas who don't say Merry
Christmas in my experience baristas do
say Merry Christmas it's the guys at the
top it's Howard Schultz it's it's the
guys who are running Starbucks it's the
guys who are running these corporations
who say Happy Holidays who say season's
greetings but why are they saying it I
get I there are a lot of people on the
right who say it doesn't matter who
cares what it's just a word but the
culture matters politics is downside
absolutely absolutely culture matters
but I don't think the culture that we
want to impose is one where we go to you
know the CEO of Starbucks and say you
better say Merry Christmas buddy how
we're gonna go get our illegal addictive
stimulants somewhere else I think you
just you'd go to Dunkin Donuts oh you go
to Starbucks because you like their
coffee not because you like their social
conservatism I love I love chick-fil-a
but I love chick-fil-a not you know
because of the social conservative
positions they take I love chick-fil-a
because it's good chicken out of
affordable price I mean isn't that what
we should be trying to do as consumers I
don't know though I mean I certainly
agree in I don't go to Starbucks because
of their politics obviously I would
never go there and yet I still do all
the time but I don't like I do like
chick-fil-a because it's a nice
wholesome company that closes on Sunday
in and out burger is fine
I know this is gonna be heresy to people
watching in California it's fine it
makes an okay burger but I what one
thing I like about them is they treat
their employees well their employees
always smile they even have Bible verses
I think on the on the bottom of the cups
there is more to it this has been the
critique all through the election on the
left and the right there's a critique
going on right now of neoliberalism of
of materialism of saying that all that
really matters is how big GDP gets and
there is a value to liberty per say
there is a value to culture per se and
there is a value to calling it like it
is
the
are not other major holidays this season
major holidays oh I totally yeah I
totally agree I mean it's a cliche but
it's a true one politics is downstream
from culture but you know the way that
you get a winning culture that is going
to affect you know positive politics is
not by beating someone over the head I
think what happens is he say out that
they're not saying Merry Christmas so
what and then you go have a better more
attractive culture and win people over
that way instead of trying to get some
godless you know fortune 500 CEO to say
words the doesn't really want to say cuz
he's gonna get made fun of at some
cocktail hour later on but I think he
ought to do it I think you're absolutely
right there it this is a more attractive
culture the culture that sees the world
correctly and calls it calls it like we
sees it and doesn't just deal in subtly
politically correct euphemisms that's
more attractive and it should be more
attractive to the dollars and Howard
Schultz better come around on that pal I
actually think that's mostly a contrived
controversy because they do put a little
Christmas lights on their cups but
certainly in other places it's not
Barack Obama made the choice to not put
the word Christmas on his Christmas card
and by the way I think the reason it's I
agree with most of your premises but I
don't exactly root the conclusion
because I think the war on Christmas is
a winning issue for us it's a winning
cultural issue most people in the United
States understand that Christmas is the
holiday this season at least here and
and that's that's what we ought to call
it like and we ought to celebrate it in
precise words on this on this point we
have to get to the the value of language
in the and the value of culture because
where where do words really matter
yesterday Elizabeth Warren claimed that
Pocahontas the word Pocahontas is a
racial slur because the president called
that ridiculous fraud a shell of a woman
is a humorless woman scolding woman he
called her Pocahontas now an actual
descendant of Pocahontas Debbie white of
perico is firing back saying quote I
know that he uses Pocahontas sometimes
with Elizabeth Warren
he said well does that offend you when I
use that and I told him no it doesn't
offend me
if Pocahontas were alive today she would
be very proud of President Trump does it
get any better than this mr. mr. blah
we're seeing a lot of old Democrat
playbooks go up in flames they're once
tried and true strategies of weaponizing
ever more specific minority categories
it just isn't working that well are we
seeing even that strategy fall apart
will that not will that be a tenable
strategy in the future yeah this is
great Michael it really is great to just
see the the the fact that they cannot do
the whole well you racist playbook
anymore is where and the reason why
they're not able to do it and this is
another reason why I think we elected
president Trump is because when he says
Pocahontas he doesn't apologize he
doesn't go oh I'm sorry I know that's
offensive to some people he just says it
let it out there everybody debates
amongst themselves and Elizabeth Warren
looks like a complete idiot and it's
great and it's over and it just goes to
show you that the second you you stop
showing that fear that they try to put
in you by saying we're gonna slander you
as a racist the second you stop showing
that they they lose and I think it's
wonderful to see that it's going up in
flames Phillip are they going to double
down on all of em - ated grievance are
they gonna learn I think it's a good
thing that this this politics of
politically correct politics is going by
the wayside I think that's one of the
benefits that we're getting with Donald
Trump but for goodness sake we didn't
elect him just so that we could say
Merry Christmas and Pocahontas I think
this is this is ridiculous that there
anyone is outraged that the president is
comparing a senator from Massachusetts
to a beloved award-winning Disney
Princess like the idea that we're so
upset about that was my mind yeah but so
here's what's interesting though about
this though is is you know Elizabeth
Warren isn't answering for the fact that
she made up and Native
heritage she's not having to apologize
for the fact that she campaigned on that
in 2012 does she talk to her fellow
faculty at Harvard about that when she
was there instead the only thing that
Elizabeth Warren is doing right now
she's counting her money on her way to
the bank I mean what President Trump did
by calling her polka not Pocahontas has
he outraged a lot of liberals a lot of
progressives and that outrage is
probably going to you know move them to
donate for for Warren and we saw this
she was out fundraising offer the
Pocahontas jab less than 12 hours after
it happened so really if we're being
honest I think that Elizabeth Warren
should thank the president because he
just he helped her fill her coffers for
chatter though I wonder because now she
is irrevocably tied to this deception
she why are we talk this is an old story
the story's been around for years and
years somehow it's the top trend on
Twitter now that Liz Warren pretended to
be Native American submitted recipes to
a Native American cookbook Wow Wow chow
we're still talking about it now I don't
know she raised money off of it but you
know who else raised money off of
insults Marco Rubio Ted Cruz Chris
Christie Jeb Bush yeah and if you ask
Low Energy Jeb and lion Ted and little
Marco and yada yada yada those went when
Trump brands you with a with a proper
title with a title that's somewhat
plausible it tends to stick he tried a
few with Hillary he tried a low stamina
or no stamina Hillary that one didn't
really work because the woman clearly
does have stamina but crooked Hillary
it's just it just sticky it sticks to
her like glue
I don't know I'm happy for Liz Warren if
she made a few bucks off of it if she if
she was able to garner a little bit of
wampum from Trump's insult but I think
that that is a sticky insult that talks
about her deception and speaking of
deceptive Democrats I think we have to
close on the weird sex stuff we've we've
beaten around the bush too long we have
to get into the today's version of the
Democrat sex scandals Matt Lauer is out
at today at the Today Show which he's
been at for I think 17 years maybe 20
years after accusations that he sexually
assaulted a staffer during the Rio
Olympics here is a now highly ironic
clip of Lauer interrogating Bill
O'Reilly over
his own harassment allegations you were
probably the last guy in the world that
they wanted to fire because you were the
guy that the ratings and the revenues
were built on you carried that Network
on your shoulders for a lot of years so
doesn't it seem safe to assume that the
people at Fox News were given a piece of
information or given some evidence that
simply made it impossible for you to
stay on at Fox News that's a false
assumption there are a lot of other
business things in play at that time and
still today that 21st century was
involved with and it was a business
decision that they made but there isn't
any information that you think makes it
is not true no it's that's not true huh
well where there's smoke there's fire
I don't know we don't know that much
about Matt Lauer these are brand new
accusations how could we oh wait a
minute here is Katie Couric you
co-hosted the Today Show with Matt Lauer
for 15 years what is Matt's most
annoying habit he pinches me on the ass
yeah that can't be good she works with
him for a very long time also Garrison
Keillor who is the longtime former host
of prairie home companion which pseudo
sophisticates insist is clever but I
just don't see it he also has ADD
because of improper sexual behavior with
regard to Matt Lauer just couldn't
happen to a nicer guy I tell ya it's
really it's it's hard not to indulge the
schadenfreude ahir because all of these
guys who are preening over women's
rights and the Republican war on women
and it's assaulting a sailing not just
women but also Republican politicians
for these issues are now going down I'm
a little worried about the moral hazards
in this environment Philip you're in the
news biz you're in the news biz down in
swampland
is there is it gonna take down the whole
industry is is this pendulum gonna swing
too far or are we just gonna take down
the rapists and that's a good thing I
mean I'm starting to think that if I
keep my hands to myself and I just
to work everyday that somehow will
magically make it to the top because
there won't be anybody left I mean so
many we've seen so many sex scandals and
it's really disparity and at this point
I mean it's a new person every single
day it seems like even every hour and
you know maybe maybe I'm unusual or
something but you know some of these
things that these guys are accused of
you know none of my friends that I hang
out with like we don't you have a locker
room jock and we certainly I don't know
of anyone any decent fellow who you know
would engage in this sort of stuff it's
not that hard to keep your hands to
yourself it really really isn't dad all
right well I hope that there's not a
clip of you coming up you know like Matt
Lauer yelling at Bill O'Reilly no I
don't think so I've heard no when a
patient's about Phillip but Paul blah
this brings up the question of the
schadenfreude should Republicans bask in
this this is great I mean jerks like
Charlie Rose Matt Lauer or Harvey
Weinstein I there isn't enough time left
in the show to go through all of these
giant Democrat mouthpieces these big gas
bags who have hypocritically talked
about women's issues for a long time but
should Republicans jump on this or are
they just opening themselves up to
getting caught not in some cases
obviously these guys raped women or
sexually assaulted them but how far will
that spectrum that blurring between
winking at your secretary and rape
raping somebody how blurry will that get
and tactically speaking do Republicans
open themselves up to a lot of unwanted
spotlight if they harp on this too much
well Michael I I don't like creeps
wherever they come from I don't care if
they're yeah III don't care if they're
Democrats III happen to think that the
democratic way of life allows for the
flourishing of creeps and creates a
culture in which the lines get so
blurred that
and men are just like so lost and
they're just like completely and totally
feeding their appetites a lot of like
feet under the bathroom stalls and Denny
Hastert and there are a lot of weird sex
stuff on the Republican side too sure
sure sure yeah the point that I'm saying
is I think that that culture breeds that
a little bit more but if you're a creep
and you're a Republican I want you gone
I mean anybody that's in a position of
power and is preying on women and can't
keep their hands to themselves can't
keep you can't keep their eyes on their
own wives and can't keep and just our
harassing women or making their lives
miserable then yeah I want you gone so I
say just let the fire let the fire burn
we'd absolutely absolutely need to make
sure that we are not engaging in a witch
hunt and that is when someone brings
forth an allegation we take it seriously
and we investigate and we find the
evidence to support it but we don't just
automatically believe them and for the
most part I think we've done a pretty
decent job at doing that right now some
cases I do think have just have been
just sort of witch-hunt scenarios just
bringing forth things from like 20 years
ago and any fun out it's like okay I
mean is this really a pattern in this
person's life but other things I think
it's it's been appropriate and I think
we're having an important watershed
moment in our culture right now it's a
distinction between the media figures
that are going down Matt Lauer Keeler
all these guys and the political figures
Al Franken has been accused of being a
sexual creep and John Conyers virtually
every politician I've ever met is a
sexual creep so I'm not surprised by any
of these I'm actually surprised by the
hubbub of around all of it but it
doesn't look like those guys are going
to be forced to step down why is that
perfectly understandable politics is
about more than just the personal
activities of the people who hold it and
as Federalist 51 points out the Congress
exists to put all of the wacko
sociopaths into one room so they can
fight each other and not destroy our
country now Philip in the case of Roy
Moore for instance he's accused of some
pretty weird stuff at least 40 years ago
and
you know truck going after young
teenagers and the like that said his
opponent in that Alabama Senate race
believes in abortion up until I believe
the fourth trimester I believe he is it
words post birth abortion I'm not sure
about the specifics of it should we
really right off Roy Moore as mister
Bois suggests because maybe he'll sexual
creep I don't mean to put words in your
mouth generally speaking if you're from
Alabama I mean and you're an evangelical
vote or your choices are pretty stark
you either vote for someone who you
think is a baby killer you either vote
for Doug Jones because you find really
more so unpalatable or you vote for
someone who's been accused of being a
pedophile right so there aren't good
options I actually mean to draw this
distinction because he's a child
molester and I'm not defending is going
after like 14 year old girls allegedly
but that is the difference right these
girls are saying they're they were very
developed there is a categorical
difference between a guy going after a
teenager in the 1970s and a guy going
after a six-year-old but they are
different Democrats are harping on it
like Roy Moore was going after and
molesting toddlers that isn't the
accusation the accusation he was
extremely creepy with young teenagers
when he shouldn't have and and in some
cases in criminal ways but that it that
is a distinction that said the opponent
wants to kill a lot of babies yeah yeah
absolutely right about that if Doug
Jones was not so radical if we had a
sort of you know if we had Joe Manchin
down in Alabama I think that he would
absolutely destroy Doug Jones and he was
just kind of moderate middle of the road
but he has become such a radical
specifically on the issue of abortion
that I don't think you're gonna have a
lot of you know sort of marginally
Republican voters down there be able to
stomach stomach that position and vote
form so I think the I I think
I'm Warner my thought is that he just
might pull this out yeah it certainly
looks that way I I'm beginning to think
that because you you can't really trust
the polls with something discharged it's
kind of like Trump it's so socially
unacceptable it's so socially taboo to
suggest that you would vote for Roy
Moore because you think protecting a lot
of babies is more important than
possibly credible accusations from four
decades ago mister blah and I'm sorry go
ahead Phillip well just jump off that
point is that gonna go you know I think
that we were talking a second ago about
how important it is to really weigh
these allegations and with the
Washington Post
I mean look I've harped on them before
for these tiny little micro scoops about
Russia that don't really end up being
things I think in the past they've
definitely overblown some stories but on
this one they cross to their T's they
doubted their eyes and then you know we
saw with the James O'Keefe video that
they're not just willing to listen to
anyone who says that 20 years ago Roy
Moore you know was trying to go after
them instead I think that they really
did good journalism and I'm I'm you know
I'm with with with mr. kawaii I mean a
human nature is universal and their
creepiness is bipartisan so I don't care
whether they're on the left or the right
I don't think they have any place
leading our country mmm mr. Bligh you're
gonna put your money where your mouth is
and say we shouldn't support Roy Moore
well I did not say that in my statement
what we are when the allegations first
broke on Moore and I was in Phatak at
the time and I said that I do think he
should step down I think we should
replace him with somebody who was more
palatable that has not happened and so
we are in a very very difficult position
and I think the the right position has
been what Trump and Sean Hannity has
said look the people of Alabama are
gonna have to decide this for themselves
I certainly if I were an I wouldn't vote
for Doug Jones or nor I I may probably
just not vote at all I know that's this
some people may just looked at as a
how are the position you might mr. one
thing there I do think that there are
just certain certain moral lines that
I'm just unwilling to cross and they
yeah I really just cannot bring myself
to just to vote for someone who could be
incredibly accused of molesting 14 year
old girl it's just even if it opens the
way for a guy who supports seventy fifth
trimester abortions to become a safe
think the answer is why I mean if more
is be incredibly accused and if he is
guilty of these things anything he
really does care about the country then
why didn't you step down when we could
have replaced somebody instead of being
a narcissist and you know trying to stay
in that's what I would say to that but
now we're just stuck in this very very
difficult position so it's kind of like
yeah it really sucks I have a very hard
time saying like yeah I want really more
to win but at the same time I really do
not want a pro abortionist is a zealot
in in the Senate it's a it's a tough
situation it's one of those things that
it's gonna come down to the wire you
know it fits in but to make Andy and
that's we would all have a Merry
Christmas Phillip last but I think you
know if we're being pragmatic here
even if Jones wins I don't see how he
you know tips the needle in favor of the
pro-choice position they've already worn
a lot of those battles but they're not
gonna win anymore when you have Trump in
the White House pragmatically though
well we're talking about way more as if
he's some sort of Republican stalwart
he's not gonna March you know lockstep
with guys like Ted Cruz or Mike Lee we
don't know what he's going to do the
only thing that we can say for certain
is that Democrats are gonna hang him
around the neck of Republicans like a
big old millstone and every time
Republicans try to push forward some
social issue there may be like not so
fast
Roy more still caucuses with you guys
yeah certainly that that's the big fear
and they'll build use it fundraise and
they'll use it to harangue Republicans
and it's it is a difficult calculation
it's a real it's not an easy one but we
don't live in solely ethereal worlds we
live in time and space and and that's
the trouble with politics is it isn't
just a rationalist intellectual exercise
we have to make usually we have to pick
one of two crappy
options and that's that's what makes
politics so frustrating and so fun and
I've had a lot of fun talking to you so
Philip thank you for being here Philip
Wegman from the Washington Examiner Paul
Cardinal blah from The Daily wire and
from st. Peters I believe if I can see
that background well that's our whole
show today get your mailbag questions in
I think we have 750 million because we
didn't do them last week on Thanksgiving
so get them in I will change your life
hopefully for the better tomorrow
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show tune in tomorrow we'll do it
all again
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
Haig supervising producer Mathis clever
our technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex's and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit all Vera the Michael null show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2017